troy can you talk about the super chat
here jacob says love the show just read
how to be an [ __ ]
so dark love it realize i already
embodied a few of the traits from my
five year
uh daytime approach why is that
important like is that
is that tied into high value you know if
you can tune into your inner [ __ ]
well thank you first of all for the uh
for the comment jacob and thanks for
for picking up the book yeah i mean well
again i think it comes down to
this distinction between what women find
attractive versus
what is perhaps considered by other guys
within a collegiate fraternity to be
high value
um if you have dark triads traits that
is to say
psychopathy narcissism and
machiavellianism
you are likely to be successful with
women because guys with those traits
tend to over index in
the number of promiscuous lovers that
they take you're also incidentally
likely
to be successful within a business
context as well because a lot of ceos
and
high performing individuals also have
those traits but does that make you a
good guy
that a group of other men are going to
sort of want to hang out with are you
honorable
are you somebody who you know you can be
trusted are you somebody that they want
to spend time with
probably not so there is a distinction
but
you know if if you look at the studies
if you look at the work that's been done
in this area
the truth of the matter is that people
who over index
in these hot dark triad traits do tend
to
get some of the cash and prizes that
they want out of life so
you know it's it's one of those things
where it depends what you mean exactly
by high value because you could be a
high value dark triad guy
who's got a string of you know lovers
and mistresses and has also made a ton
of cash
but you could also be a complete dirtbag
so
it depends where you sit in terms of
what you what you really value in in
that sort of high value sense
that's a good point i mean uh
just being honest and saying no
makes you an [ __ ] though so like yeah
just being able to say no to a girl
not an [ __ ] exactly but if you think
about like
the you know the rule zero sort of um
extended family if you like i mean all
of the people who are on board
here you know we all like each other we
all respect each other
um that's not to say that you know
individually some of us maybe we have
those traits some of us may be more than
others whatever
but individually we all come together
because there's that bond of trust and
there's that you know we know that we're
not going to screw each other over and
obviously if something does happen then
it's going to you know it's there's
going to be
consequences to that so so it's kind of
so if somebody within a group like this
suddenly started
acting like the dark triad kind of edge
lords
they'd probably get pushed out wouldn't
they because it wouldn't sit within that
framework so
do you see what i mean but there again
that's that same dude could be really
really successful successful in his own
right so there is a sort of distinction
between what we value
a really important point that you made
there is about disagreeableness and
men that are disagreeable make more
money and get more poon
than guys that are agreeable it's why
these white knight dudes that like
bend the knee to women and they have
pronouns in their twitter bio and
they're
male feminists that voted for biden they
don't get any you know they think if
they throw enough attention
or become enough of a supporter of uh
you know the feminist agenda that
they're going to get abundant you know
poon thrown at them left right and
center it doesn't work that way
and that's why you see more men running
businesses than women because men
typically
embody that trait and they become less
dis you know less agreeable and one of
the
unique things that you'll find out about
women that engage in entrepreneurship
and start up their own business not a
lot of them
i mean i've probably i'll probably say
the ratio is something like
25 to 1. um they are also disagreeable
they also start to embody these dark
triad traits i mean there's still a
little bit more on the you know let's
hold hands and sing kumbaya and they
tend to
run you know the kinds of businesses
that are like tied into that sort of
narrative
but like you get the point right yeah
yeah i think
i think there's something about being
able to
how can i put it being able to work well
with others as well
you can be dark triad you can you can do
all those stuff you can have those
qualities
but if you you also at times not all the
time but you need to have this ability
to work with others and i think we've
seen examples haven't we in our own
space where people who are
that they're so sociopathic they they
index so highly on that
that they end up screwing themselves
over because yes they've got the dark
triad stuff and
in theory that might make them somewhat
successful in one area
but also there are times where you do
need to work with other people as well
if you can't do that
you kind of end up on an island on your
own and that can be dangerous for it for
anybody
you have to be a consensus builder is
what you have to be yeah i'm glad you
brought that up rich because i've got
several essays uh written about uh dark
triad traits
um and there what was it uh
agreeableness
uh in and humility in men in men
has been associated with a negative
predictor of sex partners and i've got
just put the the link in there in the
chat right there there's a
really good uh i i don't know if this is
a meta-analysis or not but it's a really
good research
article um it's called the distance
between marg and venus measuring global
sex differences in personality
and that was one metric that they use
was uh you know
agreeableness over agreeableness uh
amen you know just basically being a
doormat kind of thing
and i i don't mean and again by order of
degrees don't don't take me in binary
extremes here
right i'm not talking about goes like
there's some like the stereotypical
kind of doormat beta male you know chump
afc
right i'm talking about like by order of
degree
most guys are probably leaning more
towards the agreeableness side of things
because they are
in they are months a majority of guys
are amongst those 80 percent of guys
that women don't want to have sex with
that don't want to reproduce with those
guys
they might they might be good candidates
for
the attractiveness side of hypergamy
they might eventually become good
candidates for
the three piece protection provisioning
and parental investment but doesn't mean
they're going to be parentally invested
in their own kids because there's
because they're agreeable
right if you're going to be if you're
going to lay down for other
like your if your base like core
personality is
based on agreeableness you're probably
going to be okay with raising another
man's child
that right there is an indicator of a
guy who is a beta male who's part of
that 80 percent
that he has a utility he has a
usefulness because he can provide and he
can
he can be at least somewhat you know at
least pay for protection if not be
physically protected
um and can be parentally invested
in in keeping the children of the guy
that she's already bred with that she's
already had
you know reproduced with that that right
there marks you
as the guy that is going to be seen as
one of the 80 percenters he's going to
be the beta males again i'm trying to
just
keep this in abstract terms here but
remember how we always say you know
women break rules for alphas and they
make rules for betas
let's focus on the make rules for beta
side right if the woman is making rules
for you
she probably sees you as agreeable she
probably thinks you'll obey
she probably thinks you're going to be
okay with those rules
wait for oh we should wait for sex and
if you can gaslight yourself if you can
incorporate that into your belief set
from i don't know okay i don't care if
you're five years old or you're 50 years
old
right if you if that's already a part of
your belief set to begin with
you've already kind of tamped down those
dark triad traits that are going to make
you attractive are going to make you
arousing anyways
in the first place because guys who are
unapologetically dark triad
are the guys that are going to be
reproducing they're the guys who are
going to be getting things done
now you have to be a consensus builder
as troy was saying there's still that
balance between being
an [ __ ] and then being a guy who
other guys like to hang out with
there's still social proof there's you
still have to be able to sort of
like bring guys together because that
builds you up in the
like the superman slash captain america
alpha
rather than the maverick [ __ ] like
tony stark right or batman on those
those kinds
so if you can blend those two together
in some way
at the in the right place at the right
time you want to know why we have such a
disparity between like women wanting to
get with this guy
at one point in their life and this guy
at another they don't even look for the
guy who might be the a good
blend of those because they only have
use for one
type of guy one type of alpha one type
of high value guy
at one particular time in their lives
that's why i wrote
preventive medicine so that you will
know at
various stages of women's maturity what
it is that they're looking for primarily
and you can
customize and cater your game so that
you can be more successful
and understand women's nature at a at 18
and
at 28 and at 38.
you